can I tell you why I don't like showing
my ass why like I'll do anything for
comedy but here's what's weird it needs
to be addressed is I have a birthmark on
my butt that looks like Australia I call
it Australia it's so real
how big is it are we talking you don't
want to call it some ass mania I will
now I have to be held by you like a baby
bird right now I'm not wearing a belt
okay okay and I love it
why do you normally yeah they're always
putting me in belts yeah you fit
constricted yeah God is literally
constricted yes this is why I bring it
up is I have a very strict no belt
policy on the weekends and you seem like
ladies you know you should go though
have yourself up at the bottom of the
screen like a crawl so when they milady
here's something like that ooh I'm
looking for a bail this man with one of
the continents on his butt
representative a person a little and
lady insane my whole life it'll be like
Sleepless in Seattle you don't I mean
where she hears yeah here's him on the
radio gonna be like that like most
gentlemen that don't rock a belt aren't
really you know an ideal mate no hmm
it's almost you're almost to a sweat
pant at that point well does he need
that careful Jesse Clarisse also easy
access though yeah that's true well
that's why we wear belts is to stop all
the and in the workplace yes Maddox
keep it under wraps yes it in this three
seconds it takes to undo it you're like
oh this is a bad idea
here's why I'm excited about your shows
because it's kind of its got like a
communal vibe it's all our friends from
UCB and you're all like living and
getting along together this I come to
utopia email had a non Johnny had a had
a dream of creating like a wanderlust
type of Micra doing I mean yeah like we
you a little bit like the village les
Gary yeah like it would be great if I
made some true Markham Oh Liam
everyone's eating it wow this is great
Wow
like like a Super Bowl party though yeah
you can just have people over for the
Super Bowl do you solve you were just
sorry
are you were myself no you can hook [__]
I gotta go nurse might get this you
gotta go pump it up all right come on
you're both gonna go pump your breast
know so you can get up tonight this is a
real pleasure to talk to you both I'm
gonna double Huggies out of ya get into
it get into it ah it's firm ladies it's
real fur I think I feel that's Trillium
I think I would Oh leg up oh that's real
you